all right I want to talk about something
that's near and dear to my heart
during the writers strike was that a
couple months ago we were trying all
kinds of things during the writers
strike and one night on the show we did
a piece where I spent some time with
someone on our staff he's an associate
producer here at late-night his name is
jordan shlonsky and yeah there he is no
he's not a magician
he's a hypnotist what kind of picture is
that I will see that in my sleep all
right
Jordan as you can tell from that picture
he's not like everyone else we learned a
lot about him he loves the rock band
Rush is his favorite rock band and he's
very proficient with an Indiana Jones
bullwhip that's one of his hobbies he
has the bullwhip and he practices all
the time and we learned all this stuff
about Jordan and since then since we
aired the piece count was people
everywhere I go say hey what happened to
that guy Jordan
is that guy for real does he still work
for you we want to see more of Jordan he
just hit some chord with people so I
thought I should spend more time with
Jordan slansky now Jordan fancies
himself a wine and food expert so I
thought who makes sense if Jordan I had
dinner together
I allowed Jordan to pick the restaurant
he took me to his favorite Italian
restaurant on the Upper East Side it's
called do way right here in Manhattan we
brought a camera crew along here's what
happened you asked me to meet you at
jouer tonight because you wanted me to
experience a fantastic Italian meal yes
a good meal good service they have the
whole package
you can look me in the eye if you want
to what I said I'm me Camille calling it
hi how are you nice to meet a Sarah he's
not really Italian you know now you two
you two hug
this is your passion is that right
correct women don't interest you food I
choose to be surrounded by beauty in all
forms as often as possible thank you
good-looking person a well-dressed
person yes a good-looking surrounding
yes I like to be in places that have
style with people that have style with
food that has style you know so much
time let's get the grub on given the
weather I would love something from
Piemonte a as you mentioned and why not
the king of all wines about although the
king of Piedmont a state awhile wrong
that's correct you like a Barolo and
almost a green one sounds good to me
I understand that was quick thank you
you mind if I look it over
yes I do thank you a quick thing I want
to tell you someone once told me that
good olive oil you can should taste like
the Tuscan Sun that make sense to you if
it's Tuscan olive oil what I mean but
you can taste the sunshine of course you
can taste the sunshine okay of course
you can say oh yeah that's interesting
when you say of course it makes me it's
feels like a put-down like oh right
idiot do not I mean you can just say
like oh yes yes that's a good point
Conant yes yes I've heard the same just
understand that these are artisanal
works this wine this olive oil are the
product of a number of factors the whole
is dirty advanced some of its paws stab
me in the head just right here and just
drive it through Jordan I are now gonna
go down stairs and meet the chef is the
chef Italian I believe he is okay if he
were not Italian with that bother you it
would be another cause for concern for
no other reason other than being that
he's Italian there's a more likely miss
that he would appreciate the art of food
yeah yeah I know what this means
he's I've just told his name his name is
who Chang Co is a qiyamah Amiga mía
Mario Mario Jordan piacere in it Mario
molto bene the beauty of the colors the
beauty of what's going on in that pan
right now the bubbling of the sauce the
excitement the energy look how the sauce
is reducing its
the steam rising off incredibly sensual
experience would you like me to call the
police go excited about the corner of a
tomato how many tomatoes have you seen
in your life they all look the same
that's not true chill out I had the
pleasure of visiting la salle de tournay
bento in the LAN game of piemonte a
probably known as one of the best
gastronomic centres of the world one of
the best restaurants in Italy so in a
good food place that's correct
it was a multi-course meal the meal
lasted for hours I had the pleasure of
being taken down to the wine cellar when
it was over and raped wait now we go
ahead took you down to the wine cellar
I'm sorry I was rude go ahead my little
joke I'm sorry I mean a little joke I
was in a small town in southern Tuscan
backing up the hallway I'm sorry go
ahead
I've got a little bit too much wine I'm
eating the whole antipasto plate myself
I'm kind of Dickie
go ahead chopper it was the night of a
very important football game after the
dinner ended I went down to the Piazza
where the entire City had gathered to
watch the game projected on a medieval
wall and you were raped
[Applause]
music tuning is very important I believe
when entertaining that music should be
playing from the moment the first person
walks in to the moment the last person
leaves I've arranged for music
[Music]
[Applause]
do you still um play with the bullwhip
sometimes I don't know if you are aware
jordiz many skills you aware that he's
an expert with a bullwhip that I didn't
know
[Music]
this tour Teno is the best I've ever had
what not about chocolate cake it's good
the moistens of the cake I'm in heaven
right now yes I wish you were this to me
one favor savor what you're about to put
in your mouth feel the combination of
textures between a gelato and the Tour
Tino feel the combination of
temperatures between the hot and the
cold you have God David you come your
mouth even cut to chef like a nice guy
eat the mush shut the pie hole well that
was a fantastic meal it's about 1:30 in
the morning Jordan and I are headed to a
German disco on the Lower East Side it's
a good night and good eating let's do it
[Music]
okay Allen's Evans oh nice landscape
okay all right
from we got a great show Jordan thank
you for that